segundo a anistia internacional o brasil
país onde mais se mata no mundo
eu não vou começar falando que eu sou
filha de uma mulher branca e de um homem
negro porque é isso mas é um pouco mais
pode ser um pouco mais complexo do que
isso a minha mãe embora ela possa ser
identificada como uma mulher não branca
ela tem um cabelo liso é bem lisa o
cabelo dela ea gente sabe como num país
como o brasil o quanto um cabelo liso
embranquece uma pessoa
o meu pai que já morreu era um homem
negro de pele escura mas tinha traços
caucasianos ou finos como as pessoas
gostam de dizer ele sim
filho de pai branco e mãe negra e nasceu
embaralhada nesse ser não ser negra
quando eu era criança eu era
identificada como uma criança branca eu
tinha uma pele muito clara o meu cabelo
era muito claro era quase loura
embora já fosse bastante cacheada ser
identificada como uma criança branca e
ser tratada como uma criança branca
longo da minha infância me fez não ver
uma série de coisas ou não perceber uma
série de coisas têm um aspecto dessa
infância lista como uma criança branca
que eu só fui entender mais tarde que é
a despeito do meu cabelo quase louro por
exemplo fui uma criança que foi da minha
de casamentos muitos muitos casamentos e
se vocês pegam esses álbuns
eu sempre estou com cabelo liso porque
mesmo branca como as pessoas achavam que
eu era mesmo achando muito fofo uma
menina loirinha de cabelos cacheados na
hora da festa aquele cabelo não era
conveniente e uma outra coisa que me
aconteceu muito as pessoas apertavam
muito meu nariz
eu cresci com as pessoas falando o
empregador de roupa pra ver se a fila um
pouquinho e eu não me identificava a
isso claro criança como uma manifestação
racista
eu só fui entender depois provavelmente
as coisas começaram a ficar um pouco
mais claras ainda que difusas
quando eu fui morar no rio eu sair da
minha cidade no interior de minas gerais
é e fui morar no rio de janeiro para
estudar e eu comecei a perceber o quanto
que era mal atendida em alguns lugares
eu chegava em lojas de shopping no rio
de janeiro e as pessoas as vendedoras me
tratavam mal eu fui seguida com muitas
vezes eu já tive que abrir minha bolsa
pra provar que eu tinha uma nota de
compra de um produto
naquela época eu entendia e associava
com uma brincadeira que a gente ouve
também ao longo da vida e só percebe o
quanto ela é racista depois que é vai
ver que eu tenho cara de pobre mas eu
não ia fundo nisso porque eu tinha cara
de pobre o que fazer para as pessoas
acharem que eu não deveria estar ali eu
não era adequado naquele lugar
bom aí eu me mudei eu fui morar em lima
no peru e lá começou uma virada em lima
quando as pessoas começaram a se referir
a mim como lá morena brasília
quando eu comecei a ser apontada como a
morena brasileira ea ser identificado e
vista pelas outras pessoas como a morena
brasileira eu comecei a falar é sobre
banca mas não era uma coisa ainda que me
parecia uma questão para se pensar
foi uma constatação então soltou branca
mas definitivo mesmo foi quando a gente
voltou a morar no brasil
a gente viveu quase oito anos em lima
mas o nosso filho mais velho tinha uns
quatro meses quando a gente se mudou ele
tinha sete anos quando a gente voltou
dois dias depois exatos dois dias depois
que a gente voltou a morar no brasil
a gente estava indo numa num café numa
loja de doces
aqui no itaim eu meu marido e meu filho
mais velho a gente atravessado a rua de
mãos dadas só que a gente meio que se
soltou as mãos e entrou nessa loja um
pouco apertado
do outro e naquela coisa de vamos sentar
e bota bolsa não sei que quando a gente
se deu conta o meu filho estava sendo
levado pelo segurança da loja para fora
da loja e foi um susto absurdo da
profunda violência que é isso
mas naquele momento eu me dei conta que
esse processo de auto identificação
étnica ele era muito mais profundo do
que eu estava vivendo até então meu
filho estava vestido completamente como
uma criança de classe média
então é claro que a motivação não foi
social
não foi um preconceito social o
preconceito racial e amplas e fiquei me
perguntando como que o segurança não
presumir que ele estava com a gente
porque finalmente eu não sou uma mulher
branca
meu marido não é um homem branco o qual
é o arcabouço mental que faz com que as
coisas sejam tão difusas e complexas no
brasil mas olhar para o meu filho e vê
uma criança negra e ver que ele é
identificado como uma criança negra
nesse país
me fez ver que o meu processo que tinha
um pouco a ver com o meu com os meus
ancestrais com meu pai com a minha vó
iaiá os meus bisavós
mas também tem a ver com o meu filho
então ele não era só sobre mim ele era
sobre nós e se foi esse momento foi uma
epifania pra mim bom e aí o meu processo
de me envolver mais no ativismo que foi
o que eu
a escolha que eu fiz porque eu precisava
me fortalecer para junto com ele nesse
caminho nessa caminhada junto com meu
filho eu vivo agora este momento em que
ele já não é mais uma criança ele tem 13
anos de idade e ele anda pela cidade
sozinho ele usa o transporte público é o
que a gente quer que ele usa o
transporte público a gente quer que ele
se apropria da cidade
a gente quer que ele seja dona da cidade
mas vocês podem imaginar que esse
estímulo convive com o pavor absoluto de
ver e saber que o meu filho de 13 anos
se aproxima mais nesse momento e desta
linha de violência profunda raça
está o que acontece nesse país que mata
jovens negros
segundo a anistia internacional o brasil
país onde mais se mata no mundo 30 mil
jovens são assassinados por ano no
brasil 77% esses jovens são negros
o que dá um número de mais de 20 de 23
mil jogos negros assassinados no ano 64
por dia mais de 2 por hora está
acontecendo agora isso está acontecendo
é um genocídio e nós estamos tristes
porque quando a gente não sai na rua e
não bati panela por isso a agência
cúmplice disso a grande maioria da
sociedade a cúmplice disso eu tenho
consciência que meu privilégio social a
minha condição de classe média protege o
meu filho de algumas coisas mas existe
uma questão que não que não poupa
ninguém que é o racismo o racismo
transversalizar qualquer classe social
eu sei que em alguma medida ele está um
pouco mais protegido com relação aos
jovens e adolescentes negros da
periferia da cidade das favelas das
comunidades de baixa renda
mas eu sei que ao andar sozinho eu não
estando com ele para protegê lo
ele vai estar exposto à violência à
violência institucional do estado a
violência das pessoas movidas pelo
racismo
meu filho agora tem 13 anos um black
lindo então ele também está passando
pelo seu processo de identificação
étnica e neste momento é eu eu convido
todo mundo a refletir junto comigo
porque eu estou em silêncio porque eu
não estou fazendo nada porque este
extermínio não tá mexendo com a minha
zona de conforto se perguntem o que eu
posso fazer o que eu posso fazer para
fazer da nossa cidade da nossa sociedade
o ambiente mas amoroso acolhedor livre
de preconceito pros nossos jovens negros
para que eles contem suas histórias
vivas seus projetos para que eles vivam
brigadas